через стефанчук виступив адвокатом
московських попід Саме так розцінює його
заяву про те що в парламентській залі
немає 226 голосів щоб заборонити цю
фсбну структуру в Україні дуже нагадує
мені ситуацію з звільненням з голови
комітету Шуфрича Коли наш проект
постанови пролежав 2,5 місяці І лише
тоді коли служба безпеки його арештувала
парламент сказала одностайно підтримала
це рішення дуже мені це нагадує
Хмельницький де обласна рада не
голосувала питання заборони Московського
патріархату до того моменту коли фсбшний
Московський піп у рясці побив церкві
Українського військового ми вимагаємо
негайно вносити проект постанови в зал і
та й ті хто насправді підтримують
русский мир і боряться проти Української
духовної Незалежності проявляться до
усій красі А ми підтримуємо і Я
переконаний фсб-шна структура буде в
Україні заборонена